we're each gonna say our craziest theory
okay okay
ray is directly related to salacious
crumb smoke is the storm trooper who hit
his head in Episode four hey everyone
Star Wars the last Jedi is out December
15th and I think we've seen everything
in terms of like trailers TVs well
probably like six more TV spots six more
TV spots that will reveal the whole
movie the internet will get furious yeah
and we'll have to hear all about it
joining me today is one of my favorite
people in the in the galaxy Alex Backus
hello comedian actor co-host of Black
Series rebels which I have been on you
have multiple times oh my gosh I stole I
stole your I killed you often I know you
you replaced me and now I'm looking for
a new job yes which is why I'm here
we're just gonna swap it's gonna come to
my show but these guys are awesome I you
should absolutely check them out they
have all this awesome merch which
they've gifted me which I just love yeah
we make these low pins for fun to help
fund the show so later in the show we
are going to have a force back moment
with Carrie Fisher from 1990 so stick
around for that
yeah yeah okay so what we're gonna do
today is run down things that we know
are going to happen in the last Jedi but
we don't know exactly where it's gonna
go and we'll talk about what we hope
it's gonna happen what's probably gonna
happen and what we really hope does not
happen yes so first things first we know
that ray and Luke are coming
face-to-face yes and it's probably not
going to go as planned as they said I
think the the line from Daisy that still
resonates with me is this idea that when
you meet your heroes sometimes they
don't live up to your expectations and
I'm very curious to see how that is
gonna play out in the last Jedi because
we all have had 40 50 years to be upset
I guess was 40 or 30 I guess 40 years
would be obsessed first yes yeah with
this moment of what would Luke
like when he gets older when he becomes
as powerful so I'm curious to see how
ray learns with the audience what he's
like now we're gonna meet Luke and he's
gonna be this like bummer up there and
we're gonna be Luke grumpy Luke he's
like gonna be super depressed obi-wan
Kenobi like if obi-wan Kenobi had no
positivity no Alec Guinness charm that's
gonna be grumpy Luke we think it's about
Rey learning to become a Jedi but I
think it's going to be more about her
hope and her positivity teaching Luke to
become a Jedi again so that's that I
think because we keep Tama who's the
last Jedi who's this who's that light
dark balance and there's something
really powerful about the apprentice
sort of bringing the master out from
maybe the the shadow so I think there's
gonna be a little bit of that I do think
raised more powerful than we could
possibly I mean we see really crack the
guy always say that earth to be octo oh
dude his face that was straight up like
out you go get off my TV spot where he
like screams in our face yes are we
really gonna go full like I hate the
phrase but gray Jedi oh my god sorry if
people out there love the phrase gray
Jedi but I'm always kind of like what
does that even mean like do we eat like
that sounds like even more of a division
I don't know cause like the grey jet I
think is like such a debate on the
Internet but I do think it's kind of
lazy yeah it's like a lazy solution it's
like thing what what happens when you
mix light and dark it's like oh it gets
less dark thousands of years know
something that's like yeah pretty decent
what's one thing with that with those
two what's one thing that if it happened
you'd be really disappointed or just
like angry in general oh I'm sorry but I
think I'm gonna light your comments up
if Rey and kylo end up in a relationship
I'm gonna be really upset and it's not
like oh how dare you put romance into
Star Wars it's just that would feel like
a complete just
throwing force awakens in the garbage
like the last we know that this movie is
a puzzle piece it fits right on top of
force awakens and last time they saw
each other she almost killed him
spoiler alert he murders his father in
front of her oh and his like her father
figure oh and his like semi Nazi
organization like blew up a yeah an
entire galaxy and it's very that would
be very like Stockholm sins yeah two
weeks two weeks later she's like yeah
I'm cool we cool we're cool fist bump
and now they're going yeah that doesn't
mean I don't see a future where they're
in some way related I personally think
it'll probably be through genes and
genetics I think they're either cousins
or siblings or something along those
lines again I don't read any of this I'm
totally like spoiler free so I'm not I'm
just theorizing but if that happens I'll
be thrilled if they just end up in a
relationship for the sake of wouldn't it
be cool if the girl who's full of hope
gets into the guy that's full of
darkness I'd be like yeah okay
my biggest thing that I would hate so
much as if Luke turned to the dark side
yeah yes that's up there I feel like we
have been through this whole journey
with this guy we went through the
original trilogy with him he has been
tested so many times and he is just you
know unbreakable I understand that he's
been questioning everything about
himself and kylo Ren turned on him and
then he went to octo and was like I have
to rethink my whole life and I don't
know if I you know I I think the Jedi
needs to end I messed up yeah but I
don't think that he would go dark yeah
and I think again it's like we that
would be a complete just throwing away
what happens in returnable data he goes
all the way to the edge that's the whole
point
it's like he's hitting Vader Vader's
like ah don't kill me kid and then the
Vader gets up and he's like no I won't
do it he throws a saber I'm a Jedi like
my father before me that's like I'm a
Jedi like my father before me until
things get worse and then I'm like I'm
going dark baby
you've had the ultimate test and then
you would go back and watch the original
trilogy and be like well this is crazy
but like it's gonna get worse for him
and he's gonna go dark I'm like I don't
know we just start to like retcon and
like pick apart moments or would be like
oh here's where heals and that being
said I will always die on the sword of
in Ryan we trust so if you can do any of
this stuff in a way that surprises me
and AHS me then I won't care but we've
had so much time to think about what
could happen if it's just like Luke's
bad now I'll be like oh I hope for the
love of God we like this movie because
he's doing like a whole nother trilogy
after so I mean that has to be the
ultimate stamp of approval right like
you don't give somebody a ton of jobs
when they did a bad job you would assume
that they're like this is pretty good do
you thing we're gonna find out parent
Asian up in in the last Jedi yes in the
last oh yes a hundred percent I think
we're gonna find out parentage in the
last ever who do you think if you had to
guess do you think it's like we've never
met them in the world it doesn't matter
it's somebody we know um I have a bet
with a friend okay and I'm probably
gonna lose this bet but I think Han and
Leia are her parents why do you think
that well there's a couple of things one
I think that ads are really amazing
dynamic between kylo and her which is
clearly the thing they're playing up
like what what stakes are as high as
he's your father it's like oh he's your
brother oh and by the way he murdered
your father in front of you and you had
no idea or you at least were unaware of
what was happening also why is the
Falcon just parked on Jack ooh and right
when they get out of orbit Hans just
like oh hey what's up here's a blaster
you want to be my co-pilot like those
are not Han Solo traits han after five
minutes doesn't go you seem like a nice
person would you like to join the crew
do you know what I mean so that just to
me it always kind of felt like Han is
just being the obi-wan of force awakens
he's looking after this person and his
ways over the years and he's kind of
last of this fussing Rey he's like
taking her
and totally fill the void that lost
child that absolutely could be the case
and I think if that is the case then I
hope that she is either a product of the
force like Anakin I don't know how I
would feel about her just being nobody
because then why does that lightsaber
call to her yeah why make such a big
deal of it and then why the Maz Kanata
mom who's the girl and then they cut
away like if she's nobody why cut away
why did you say I don't know some lady
who stole my ship and now I I have it
back and she seems like she's really
nice though might give her a job will it
work out probably not and I'm probably
gonna lose that bet but I just feel like
I want that moment that is as impactful
as I am your father but not as obvious
as Luke saying to ray I'm your father
right Star Wars is at its best one it's
simple yeah when you don't need to read
15 books and play all the games and
watch all of the animated series like I
always go to that that Ezra being Snoke
theory could you imagine now if during
that movie Snoke looks like super
intense and goes I was once a Jedi
Ezra Bridger and like everyone in the
theater except for four people would be
like oh like four people back yes I
watch rebels I get that so it's not that
I don't love rebels it's just those the
the movies need two standalone pieces of
cinema someone needs to be able to walk
into last Jedi and go I can watch this
without seeing any other episodes of
Star Wars you can watch Empire Strikes
Back without seeing a new hope and still
think it's an awesome movie right I
think the Easter eggs are nice were like
oh my god like there's chopper in or
whatever but that's perfect but when
they have and then they call like a hare
over the nuts that's great oh yeah what
if they like how to walk anyway I'm hair
I'd be like no I'm Harrison dule you can
catch me once a week on Disney XD this
is really a really force really forced
oh boy that's it everybody everybody
have a good night yeah I want to talk
about - uh Finn and phasma as well
because we know you have this like crazy
showdown that game looks like it's like
at the Coleman
of the movie like buckling around or
whatever they're on whatever ship or
base is not having a good day I think
one of them will go down in that battle
I know like I don't feel like they're
both gonna be like alright let's get out
like we both gonna get on our respective
ships and get out of here in the nick of
time
the only way I will be okay a finn goes
is he has to have his reunion with Rey
yes they he can't die you can't open the
movie like cuz we've seen in another
random trailer was like where's ray yeah
yeah you can't say where's ray not see
her and then die like you must have a
million questions and he's like nah just
where's ready one final thing here is
the pork yes
I'm mama I'm a member of pork nation
good good everyone should join it's just
you just use the hashtag pork nation on
Twitter and you're a member I think that
the pork is very telling of what a good
storyteller Rian Johnson is and I know
you're like what why is the poor do that
yeah that's exactly it's because I think
they're chewy service animal that little
guy in the Falcon is how he loses his
best friend yeah well that's just like
hey man stop it we're in a battle like
it looks super aggressive but I
guarantee that port probably at
something goes I know trying to push the
button yeah a bright Hoffs attack up
there yeah cuz I always thought I was
like oh this is like his little buddy
that he takes along oh for sure like I
think that's like that's like no that's
like that's no different than like c-3po
bumpkin r2 like ah I wish there was like
a livestream of my face when I saw that
for the first time that came out of
nowhere and everyone was like tagging me
in it that was Thanksgiving I was like
yeah I think what I love that it
instantly was like that just goes to
show you how lovely and how terrible the
internet internet could be all at the
same time they were like oh yeah let's
show us the ash that'll really hurt her
feelings it's like Oh guys he's just
chill on the porch they're just they're
just penguins it's not just they're just
little like puffins inspired you think
they'll have names this is oh my gosh
been talking about this for so long and
I I cannot get an answer out of anybody
do the porks have individual names I'll
ask you this because I'm very curious do
you think any porks will get harmed that
that is assuming that that hit isn't a
harmful move I just I worry about my own
mental health if a poor gets eaten in
the last Jedi because people will I'm
gonna have to like deactivate my Twitter
account I guess I just don't see a world
where in the trailer they have this like
triumphant wookie roaring pork and then
Julie's like that was really cute
I'm gonna I think that that that feather
thing on his mouth was it is like he was
probably flying around causing up a
ruckus and they're like you know it
would be funny put it on his mouth for
the behind-the-scenes so people will
think that Chewie eat support yeah if
they were smaller I'd be like Oh Chuy's
just like puts it in his mouth and
they're like spit it out chewy and he's
like yeah but I don't think they're too
big maybe it was just a kiss maybe it
was like hey we're buddies
maybe that's the romance weird too weird
which brings us to our force back a
moment of the week
with the amazing Carrie Fisher from 1990
we're digging into our et vault and
she's got a lot to say about Princess
Leia the character so take up oh I mean
sometimes people to get me to turn
around
hey Princess Leia like I'm gonna he's
gonna be sewing yes oh yeah people my
grandmother named her dog Princess Leia
and it was subsequently hit by a car so
I have other connotations that can kind
of permeate it that are not as pleasant
but I mean I like it all right I don't
like after 30 which I know him this is
the after 30 part I don't like being
called Princess Leia in airports and
stuff but that probably won't stop
unless Fisher would do no stretch I like
it I'd like a nickname at this point
this clip made me wonder if when she got
cast for force awakens if she was like
hey JJ I'll be back in your movie but
I'm never going back this way ever again
you better change me to general maybe I
could see that like
she would be like a general by now yeah
right she's not the princess anymore but
isn't that technically a step down right
royalty to leader of the military I
guess that you up your and more probably
gets more power if princesses just sort
of pomp and circumstance like just like
I'm a princess but we know that that's
not all Leia I never really viewed her
as like hoity-toity princess I took it
as like no she's like a warrior from
Alderaan but they call it the princess
is just like yeah like we view it here
on earth in the galaxy far far away it's
like a prestigious time yes and you
wield a weapon yeah and you go you're in
the trenches and I think that that's why
I don't think it Everly through anybody
optic collar general okay chef she's
generally know whatever it doesn't
matter she's always cool or Suntech oh
yeah he's like yeah she's she's rather
lord Sant'Agata like afterwards pose
like hey by the way she really prefers
general that's what we didn't seems like
nope to me she's roiled yeah he's like
we got company runs out and goes I can
he's like by the way by the way don't
sit in front of her call it so it's a
little dismissive when you call her
princess now and he's like well I'm old
I can't wait to see her
what like I've we've seen a couple of
her hair styles but that's like the
thing that Carrie Fisher was always just
like I hate my hairstyle it yes I think
she looks awesome in last Jedi though oh
my gosh they're like really ornate
beautiful yeah scary like what's that
start All Saints
you know also it's like All Saints
clothes it's like British goth
it's like oh I just went to All Saints
and I got this really high transpired a
dress every day it's like high tracks
it's kind of like the like the turtle
like you could just like yes her cuz she
could be in a meeting and be like you
know what what do you think we should do
in regards to guy did you hear your son
killed Han Solo he's like any time
things get rough she just ducks ducks
and into her I love it well I want to
thank you so much for coming by thank
you for having me you've got to collab
on this side mm-hmm and actually I will
be on your show on Sunday
yeah we're gonna be doing a very similar
thing except way less professional and
way more Wayne's World II and it's gonna
be there probably some pajamas and poor
like we're just gonna be might we're
just gonna sleep from I mean I'm
planning on a clown as soon as that's
done I'm going social media dark I'm
going up going dark to I'm gonna sleep
until Thursday I'm gonna sleep until I
see the movie at 7:00 you've got your
tickets and everything oh come on I got
the whole week
I got ya we're I'm all planned out yeah
well yes since we will be going social
media you guys can tweet us and we'll
read them all when we come back I guess
after everybody sees you tell us how
wrong we were this right and wrong I
think we probably got everything right
but yeah tell everybody where they can
they can find you you guys can find me
on Twitter at my personal Twitter handle
at Alex underscore abacus or you can
find Black Series rebels at blk series
rebels
we're also on YouTube you can subscribe
to all that good stuff and you can find
me at ash Crossing and come back here
every Thursday for a new episode to talk
about likely Star Wars make sure you hit
that like button subscribe and comment
let me know what your craziest /ni
theory is and we'll talk about it I'll
see you guys next time